what's going on guys in this video i'll
be going through every clue in the micro
academia manga and anime
that indicates that dabby is the son of
endeavor
despite having previously done theories
about dabby's childhood and his future
it occurred to me that i've never once
done a video on why i'm so sure
he's a todoroki in the first place today
we're going through
all the evidence that supports this idea
all the way up to the latest chapters in
the manga so
spoiler warning for those of you who
don't want to know anything beyond
season four
the first question we should start with
is who exactly
is toyotaroki as we all know from the
sports festival
endeavour sought to create a child with
the potential to surpass all might
and toyo was the first of his lab rats
despite being the eldest child
we can see here that his growth was
clearly stunted when compared to his
other siblings
and endeavour referred to toya as having
a weak constitution
throughout the series we've had several
instances of dabi having a weak
constitution
with one of the more subtle examples
being back in the overhaul arc
during their ambush of the police debbie
mentions to spinner how he gets carsick
and tells the lizard to stop swerving on
the road none of the other villains had
a problem with spinner's driving so
it was interesting that horukoshi went
out of his way to give dabi this panel
just to complain about his car sickness
when we flash forward to the myvillan
academia arc
we see again how frail dabby's body is
as his face randomly starts to bleed
despite not taking
any damage at that point like he didn't
take any hits or anything like that
and the overuse of his quirk began to
make his skin
look like it was gonna fall off that
battle was our first example
of just how much dabby's body can't
really handle his firepower
as we see consistent panels of smoke
emanating from his
from his mouth and from his arms this
wasn't the end of it though
as during the war arc we see again that
dabby continues to burn his own body
with the smoke being more prominent than
ever before
looking back at endeavour's words about
toya the full sentence was that the boy
possessed
even greater firepower than endeavour
himself but inherited
his mother's weak constitution we now
know that debbie fulfills the criteria
for having this weak body
but what about his firepower as i'm sure
you've all noticed
dabby has had blue flames ever since his
introduction to the series
and thanks to a quick google search it
is correct to say that blue flames are
indeed hotter
than the orange flames that we typically
see from endeavour
whilst the big guy was able to use blue
flames once in the anime
his level of firepower has never been
enough to do it consistently
which is why he must have considered
toyah to be even more impressive than
himself
as a result before we move on we've
confirmed that based on this statement
from endeavour
derby fulfills the criteria to be toyah
because he has greater firepower
and a weak constitution next up
let's take a look at some interesting
things dabi has said about the todoroki
family
the pro hero arc was the first time that
dabi and endeavour came face to face and
what's important to remember about this
interaction
is that endeavour had just finished an
exhausting fight with the hyen nomu
and had severely damaged his eye
therefore when he was looking at dabi
his vision was totally blurry as it says
here which
obviously gives him a perfect excuse to
not recognize his own son
in this moment the first giveaway that
debbie already knew endeavor
is when he looks at the hero and asks
should i say nice to meet you
and we can see that the nice to meet you
part is in bold
which implies that it wasn't a serious
question he then goes on to say that
he and endeavor should have a chat
whilst they have this chance
which makes it seem like number one
there's something he wants to talk to
endeavor about
and number two that he's been waiting
for the right opportunity to do it
as dabi began to escape he specifically
refers to endeavour
as ng todoroki which is his full legal
name
this is suspicious because there are
only three occasions in the manga
when dabi has ever referred to someone
by his full name
the first being when he encountered
shoto todoroki the second being when he
met engie todoroki
and the final being during his fight
with hawks
each of those situations was unique but
there's one thing that makes his meeting
with
shoto and endeavour particularly special
these were the first times that dabby
had encountered those characters you
know
it was the first time he had met shoto
and he called him by his full name
and it was the first time he had met
endeavour and he also called him by his
full name
what reason is there for this weird
formality with the todoroki family
as a quick comparison you know bakugou
was the kid that he was kidnapping and
he didn't refer to bakago by his full
name
in my opinion this is a subtle hint
towards his connection to the todoroki
family
the other suspicious moment that
happened during the pro hero arc
was how dabby excitedly looked forward
to getting another chance to talk with
endeavour in the future
and he says that he hopes endeavour can
stay alive until they next get the
chance to meet
if we flash forward to chapter 231 dabi
again shows that he prioritizes
endeavour's life
as he orders hawks to kill any hero
except the number one
i need you guys to appreciate how
ridiculous that is because
debbie says here that hawks must kill
someone to show his loyalty to the
anti-establishment cause
and there would be nothing more
anti-establishment than killing the
number one hero
yet for some reason dabby doesn't want
that to happen
clearly whatever message that dabby
wants to tell endeavour
it's so important that it almost
overrides
what his main goal what you would assume
his main goal would be
therefore to recap everything so far
debbie fits endeavour's description of
toyotaroki
and he has a specific message that he
wants to tell endeavor
and refuses to let anything happen to
endeavour until he can do that
he also refers to members of the
todoroki family by their full names
despite only meeting them for the first
time supposedly
it's only todoroki family members that
get this treatment
now moving on all members of the
todoroki family
believe that toya is dead and we see
that endeavor has built a memorial
dedicated to his oldest son toya's age
in this photo
basically confirms that his death
happened around 10 years ago
but let me explain why toyo was the
oldest child
which by default makes him between three
to four years older than natsuo
natsuo was 19 when we first met him
meaning that if dabi is toyah
he's at least 22 when we first see him
in the anime but he's also possibly 23
years old or 24.
therefore 10 years ago debbie would have
been middle school age
which is when this final photo was taken
before toya's death
this is important because during the
sports festival
allmight revealed that he hadn't seen
endeavor since a press conference
10 years ago what was this press
conference that occurred around the time
of toyah's death
and why later in the manga did endeavour
reveal that he may as well have killed
toya himself
is it not possible that the press
conference that omai is referring to
was somehow related to the incident that
killed toya
and perhaps by endeavour failing to stop
this incident
maybe that's why he bears some
responsibility for what happened
i certainly think it's plausible that
this is related but let me know your
thoughts on it down below
moving on it's a fact that natsuo was
very close with his older brother
and stated that toyo always told him
everything it's for that reason that 10
years later
natsuo can still not forgive endeavor
and cries at the memories
of what happened back in the day
natsuo's relationship with toyah is very
relevant
when we look at this incident of daby
crying in chapter 191
and i'm going to explain why it's likely
that he shed tears about natsuo in this
moment
for full context of this scene dabi had
previously killed the pro hero
called snatch and just before he dealt
the finishing blow
the hero asked abby if he ever thought
about the families who have to live with
the loss
because of darby's actions we know that
the todoroki family
suffered the loss of their eldest son 10
years ago and i think this statement by
snatch
is what caused daby to for once think
about those who are living with the loss
of toyah's death it's clear he doesn't
care about endeavour or shoto
but one person who could cause him to
shed bloody tears like this
would be his little brother natsuo
remember that in the chapter immediately
after we see dabi crying
natsuo angrily shouts an endeavor and
refers to some unknown incident
involving his big bro toyah furthermore
when the younger brother visited their
mother in the hospital
he mentioned again how he couldn't
forgive endeavor for what he did to her
what he did to shoto and what he did to
a mystery person who is
obviously toyah on both occasions when
natsu mentioned his older brother
he was unable to finish this sentence
and he never quite elaborated on what
exactly happened to toya
which indicates the events must have
been quite traumatizing
with all that said an interesting piece
of trivia before we move on to the next
part
is that endeavours memorial tutoria is
presumably located in toyo's old room
as we see this football in the corner
which we know he's played with in the
past
other things that support the idea that
dabi is toyah includes his physical
features
specifically his eyes his smile and his
skin grafts
to start with the eyes we've seen a wide
variety of eyes in the series
ranging from the myrial eyes to the deku
eyes to the izawa eyes
basically there's a wide variation of
different eye designs
this makes it interesting when we
compare shoto dabi and endeavor
because they have near identical eyes
when it comes to both the color
and the the shape and the design of them
and when we then compare them to toya
himself
you'll see that the similarity remains
another eye comparison that was quite
interesting
was how dabby's angry eyes that we saw
during modern academia
were almost like a mirror image of ray
todoroki's eyes
when she had a mental breakdown
regardless though
dabi's most defining physical feature is
the skin grass that he has stapled
all over his body skin grafts are
patches of skin that are placed on top
of areas that have been previously burnt
and the fact that debbie has these skin
grafts indicates that he's been through
some kind of trauma that burned off
parts of his skin
when we remember that toyotaroki had a
weak constitution
that couldn't handle his own flames it
all starts to come together
if toya survived the accident that
supposedly killed him
then it's probable he'd need skin grafts
similar to what debbie has now
when we take a look at his smile you'll
notice that in recent chapters he's been
smiling a lot
and i thought that this panel of him
here was very reminiscent of this panel
of fuyumi who is
presumably his younger sister i thought
their smiles look
relatively similar here like the design
you could believe that they were
siblings just based on how similar these
smiles look
the final piece of relevant information
that links debbie to toya
is the fact that dabi's real name has
been consistently kept a secret
from the very beginning during their
first encounter
shigaraki asks dabi for his real name
and the villain refused to say it
telling shigeraki that he'll know when
he needs to know it
then when we flush forward to kamino
gran torino and the police were able to
uncover the names
of all the league of villain members
except darby and shiguraki
after this a similar thing happened
during the war arc
when hawks looked into the villain's
backstories and he said that he could
find information on everyone
except darby and shiguraki again i did a
theory video explaining why i believe
diabetes identity is so hard to uncover
but it's important to note that this is
this is by dabi's own design
literally none of the villains know what
his real name is despite him spending
99 of his time with them and it was
therefore a big surprise
when dabi straight up told hawkes what
his name was in chapter 267
we as an audience weren't able to see
what it was but hawke's reaction tells
us that it's a name he recognizes
if he is a todoroki from hawks's
perspective it's a big deal because
we all know hawkes is a massive fan of
endeavor um and
he's worked closely with endeavour so to
hear that this is a todoroki or
endeavour's son yeah i mean i would
react like this as well
based on the clues that i've presented
in this video those are the reasons why
i think that dabi has to be toyotaroki
it's not guaranteed but in my opinion it
is but you may think differently
if you like this video then i would
really appreciate it if you would
subscribe
and until the next one peace out